[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe neulich am Wochenende Pfannenbrot zubereitet,
weil nämlich die Bäckereien zuhatten.
Es war ein Feiertag.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht:
"Mensch, machen wir doch Bazlama!"
Bazlama, das ist so ein richtig luftiges, fluffiges Brot.
Ich mag zwar das Wort nicht,
aber ein anderes Wort
beschreibt die Konsistenz einfach nicht.
Also ein schönes fluffiges Brot aus der Pfanne.
Könnt ihr super vorbereiten.
Und die Mädels, also Samira und Ela,
sie hatten auch superviel Spaß dabei, mir zu helfen.
Ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten.
Die habe ich persönlich immer zu Hause.
Das heißt, immer dann, wenn wir mal kein Brot dahaben,
und ich ein bisschen Zeit habe,
mache ich dieses Pfannenbrot.
Für den Teig nehme ich einen Würfel Hefe,
450 Gramm warmes Wasser,
einen Teelöffel Zucker,
900 Gramm Mehl,
– ich habe jetzt Dinkelmehl –
einen Teelöffel Backpulver,
zwei Eier,
70 Gramm Milch,
– die ist bereits warm –
40 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl
und einen Esslöffel Salz.
Ich gebe jetzt hier die Hefe einfach in eine Rührschüssel.
Wie immer, könnt ihr den Teig auch mit der Hand verkneten.
Das Wasser kommt jetzt direkt dazu.
Und da solltet ihr einfach immer nur darauf achten,
dass das Wasser nicht zu heiß ist,
also wirklich nur lauwarm.
Den Zucker mit rein.
Und jetzt ganz kurz auflösen.
Ich muss jetzt hier sagen, dass ich gefrorene Hefe habe.
Ich friere Hefe gerne auf Vorrat ein.
Wenn ich nämlich keine frische dahabe,
nehme ich sei einfach raus.
Das heißt, ich löse die jetzt hier einfach im warmen Wasser.
Wenn ihr dran denkt, könnt ihr sie auch am Abend vorher
einfach in den Kühlschrank stellen zum Auftauen.
Oder eben im warmen Wasser jetzt auftauen.
[Musik]
Hier vermische ich jetzt schon mal die trockenen Zutaten,
also Mehl, Backpulver und Salz.
Es sieht nach ziemlich viel Salz aus,
aber ich habe ja auch ein Kilo Brot.
Also so viel ist es dann nicht.
Und der Geschmack passt dann perfekt.
Das gebe ich jetzt hier mit rein.
Und je nach Mehlsorte kann es sein,
dass ihr einfach bis zu 50 Gramm mehr oder weniger braucht.
Ich habe es jetzt bei mir schon getestet, wie gesagt.
Mit Dinkelmehl da passt die Menge perfekt.
Wenn ihr jetzt Weizen habt, kann es sein,
dass ihr einfach ein bisschen mehr braucht,
weil Dinkel eben mehr Flüssigkeit bindet
und mehr Flüssigkeit einfach benötigt.
Dann gebe ich hier die zwei Eier rein,
– die sorgen dafür, dass der Teig wirklich schön locker wird –
die Milch
und das Öl.
Und da habe ich jetzt einfach ein Sonnenblumenöl,
weil es geschmacksneutral ist.
So.
Das war es schon.
Kurz auskratzen.
Und jetzt einfach den Teig verkneten.
Entweder mit der Hand fünf bis sieben Minuten
oder eben mit der Küchenmaschine.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach noch die 34°C eingestellt.
So kann der Teig direkt vorwärmen
und geht später besser auf.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt einfach so ein bisschen Backtrennspray
und kann hier noch schön die Reste abkratzen.
Und das ist jetzt so ein Brot, das reicht
– also wir waren zu dritt, drei Erwachsene und zwei Kinder
und hatten noch was übrig.
Also es hätte noch ein Erwachsener
oder noch mal zwei Kinder hätten da mitessen können.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht,
wie viel ihr morgens esst,
aber für uns war es echt die perfekte Portion
und wir hatten sogar für den nächsten Tag noch was übrig.
Und das kann man dann einfach am nächsten Tag
perfekt entweder im Backofen kurz aufbacken
oder in so einem Toaster.
Das funktioniert prima.
Ihr seht, das ist so ein weicher Teig.
Der darf ruhig auch etwas weich bleiben,
auch wenn er dadurch ein bisschen klebt.
So.
Jetzt kann ich hier die Schüssel schön fetten
und versuchen, den Teig zu einer Kugel zu formen.
Ansonsten nehmt ihr einfach ein bisschen Mehl zur Hilfe.
Aber ich lasse den jetzt tatsächlich
gerne lieber etwas weicher,
damit sie eben auch schön fluffig und luftig werden.
So.
Reinlegen,
mit Fett besprühen
– so trocknet die Oberfläche nicht aus –
und ich werde es jetzt einfach
bei Gärstufe im Backofen aufgehen lassen.
Da braucht es nämlich wirklich nur 30 Minuten
statt eine Stunde.
Ihr könnt es aber auch gerne abdecken
bei Raumtemperatur oder an einem warmen, kuscheligen Ort
einfach für eine Stunde aufgehen lassen.
Bei Gärstufe muss man den Teig auch nicht abdecken.
Also da kann man wirklich die Oberfläche offen lassen.
Denn es kommt ja Wasserdampf dazu
und der sorgt dafür, dass der Teig schnell und gut aufgeht,
ohne dabei auszutrocknen.
Das perfekte Klima sozusagen.
Wasser ist drin.
Jetzt nur noch einstellen.
[Musik]
So sieht der Hefeteig bereits nach einer halben Stunde aus!
Woah!
Hammer!
Mein Gott!
Das ist immer so...
Das sind diese Satisfying Moments.
Dieses Wow.
Okay.
Jetzt verwende ich etwas Mehl.
Wie gesagt, ist der Teig ja auch recht weich.
Dimm dimm dim.
Guckt mal. Ich verteile das dann immer so schön.
Und jetzt ausschütten.
Ich sage nichts.
Wir machen einen ASMR Moment daraus,
ein Most Satisfying Videos on YouTube.
Tschuh!
O mein Gott!
Wisst ihr, warum ich Hefeteig liebe?
Darum!
Wow!
Okay.
Ich darf mich nicht selbst vergessen hier.
Und ich forme jetzt hier einfach Bällchen
mit etwa 120 Gramm.
Ihr könnt sie gerne abwiegen oder nach Augenmaß arbeiten.
Und, wenn ihr sagt,
ihr seid im Augenmaßportionieren nicht ganz so gut,
dann macht ihr es so,
dass ihr praktisch hier eine Rolle daraus formt
und dann Stücke abschneidet
oder ihr formt einen runden Kreis
und nehmt zum Beispiel einen Torteneinteiler
und habt dann die Portionen.
Oder ihr nehmt euch einfach eine Waage
und wiegt es ab.
So kann man jetzt einfach diese Kreise formen,
diese Kugeln formen.
#00:06:48-50# Das könnt ihr auch so machen.
Das haben Samira und Ela auch richtig süß gemacht.
Also ich lasse die dann auch echt
am Wochenende einfach mitbacken.
Denn die Kids haben Spaß dabei
und dann sehen sie auch, wie Brot hergestellt wird,
wissen welche Zutaten reinkommen,
und sie essen es dann eben auch viel, viel lieber.
>> MURAT: So. Wir machen...
Wir haben endlich mal ausgeschlafen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Und dann sind wir zum Bäcker
und dann haben wir gemerkt, dass der Bäcker heute zuhat.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich habe es noch vermutet.
Aber es war ein schöner Spaziergang.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt machen wir einfach
Brot selber, nicht, Schatz?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Was machen wir? Wie heißt das?
>> SAMIRA: Bazlima?
>> MURAT: Nein, Bazlama.
>> SAMIRA: Ach so.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Und wenn es nicht klappt, mache ich
– nehme ich das immer so nach innen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: So. Und dann forme ich noch mal so.
>> SALLY: Guck. Du musst praktisch mit deinen Händen
so machen, dass es so von außen nach innen geht.
So.
>> SAMIRA: So?
>> SALLY: Guck. So.
So.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Und dann rollst du hier so.
Und dann geht das praktisch so von außen nach innen.
Und deswegen auch kein Mehl nehmen,
damit man praktisch auf der Matte
mit diesem Silikon arbeiten kann.
>> ELA: Darf ich auch, Mama?
>> SALLY: Einfach 3 mm ausrollen.
>> ELA: Mama, darf ich auch?
>> SALLY: Du darfst auch gleich. Ja.
Lass die Samira ein paar machen und du darfst auch.
Und hier Vorsicht.
>> ELA: Darf sie diese alle machen?
>> SALLY: Samira darf einige und du darfst.
Guck mal. Jetzt sind sie immer gleichmäßig.
Guck. Einmal so bis komplett darüber rollen.
>> MURAT: Hat die eine schwarze Nase?
>> SALLY: Nein, die hat Mehl auf der Nase.
Dann hast du praktisch immer 3 mm, alle gleichmäßig.
Okay?
Komm, ich nehme es ein bisschen zur Seite.
Dann kannst du, genau, das nächste machen.
>> SAMIRA: Die sind so schön fluffig!
>> SALLY: Gell?
>> MURAT: Jetzt machst du das ohne Öl oder irgendwas?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Also entweder beschichtete Pfanne oder Edelstahlpfanne.
Egal.
Ich mache es aber jetzt hier, weil...
Und hier rollen.
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe es gehört!
>> SALLY: Und du kannst nichts falsch machen,
weil der rollt ja jetzt sowieso auf 3 mm aus.
Genau.
Einfach von vorne bis hinten.
Guck.  Hier auch darüber, damit das nicht dick bleibt.
>> SAMIRA: Warte! Warte!
Ela,...
>> SALLY: Nee, (?) ie kann es auch so lassen.
Du musst es nicht drehen.
>> SAMIRA: Aber...
>> SALLY: Lass sie. Lass mal die Ela.
Halt.
>> ELA: Hey!
>> SALLY: Ganz genau.
Und jetzt so weg.
Und jetzt einmal noch so.
Das wollte dir die Samira zeigen.
Perfekt!
>> MURAT: Woah, voll cool!
>> SALLY: Siehst du? Hier kannst du nichts falsch machen.
Mach – guck mal – aber immer bis zum Schluss rollen,
dass es von vorne bis hinten
einmal so darüber gerollt ist.
So.
Nächstes.
>> SAMIRA: So.
>> SALLY: Bitte schön, Ela.
Hier.
>> ELA: Wer macht dieses Röllchen?
>> SALLY: Dann immer schön von vorne bis hinten.
Das machst auch du.
>> SAMIRA: Da hat sich gerade die Luftblase
da drinnen gebildet!
>> SALLY: Super!
Jetzt kannst du es auch noch mal drehen
und wieder rollen.
>> SAMIRA: Woah!
>> SALLY: Sieht schon gut aus.
>> SAMIRA: Wie lecker das aussieht!
>> SALLY: Das brauchen wir ja jetzt nicht so dunkel.
>> MURAT: Das kann man einfach
in einer Edelstahlpfanne machen?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Wir haben...
>> MURAT: Kann man das auch
in einer beschichteten Pfanne machen?
>> SALLY: Oder beschichtet. Genau.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und einfach ohne Fett.
Ihr seht ja, das klebt nicht an.
Das ist wie in der Türkei dann
>> SAMIRA: Ja!
>> SALLY: auf dem Saç.
Dann könnt ihr hier so ein kleines Blech nehmen,
ein Pizzablech zum Beispiel
oder auch ein großes Ofenblech.
Einfach mit Mehl bestreuen.
Denn wichtig ist, damit die wirklich auch schön luftig werden,
die noch mal aufgehen zu lassen.
Also mit ein bisschen Abstand hier auf das Blech.
Guckt mal. Ihr könnt auch
immer ganz gut zwei gleichzeitig machen.
Und da gucke ich immer,
dass nicht so viel Mehl auf der Matte ist.
Dann geht es besser.
Praktisch umdrehen
und dann die Hand so rund um den Teig legen
und einfach Kugeln formen.
Und die Finger, die transportieren praktisch
die Oberfläche immer wieder nach unten,
sodass sich die Teigkugel auch schön glättet.
Und dann sieht das so aus.
Das macht halt dann auch Spaß.
An so einem Sonntagmorgen
dich so mit so Teig zu beschäftigen,
ist so ein schöner Start in den Tag, finde ich.
Es war dann an dem Tag
erst mal so ein schöner Ausflug zur Bäckerei.
Wir so: "Hey, wir laufen heute alle gemeinsam zur Bäckerei!"
Und Samira mit dem Roller oder Inliner,
Ela mit ihrem Fahrrad.
Und dann standen wir vor dem Bäcker
und der war einfach zu.
Und ich: "Hey, wir laufen wieder nach Hause!
Kommt, wir machen Brot!"
"Okay."
War halt ein Spaziergang dann.
Jetzt darf mein erstes Blech schon mal
wieder in den Ofen zurück.
Also entweder abdecken wieder
mit einem Tuch zum Beispiel
und etwa 20, 25 Minuten aufgehen lassen
oder noch mal im Dampfbackofen für 10 Minuten.
Das reicht dann auch schon.
[Musik]
Ach, sehen die schön aus!
Sehen die nicht schön aus?
Ja, sie sehen schön aus.
Und ich mache es jetzt so,
ich werde jetzt gleich vier Brote auf einmal ausbacken
und nehme mir schon mal vier Teigbällchen.
Und den Rest packe ich wieder zurück.
Also immer schön wieder abdecken
oder einfach in den Ofen stellen,
damit sie einfach nicht austrocknen
und schön weiter aufgehen können.
So.
Und jetzt habe ich es mit den Kindern so gemacht
– denn, wenn ich jetzt den Kindern sage,
"Samira, Ela, rollt mal den Teig auf 5 mm Dicke aus",
passiert es natürlich schnell,
dass es nicht so gleichmäßig ausgerollt wird.
Und das ist jetzt auch das Geheimnis hinter dem Brot.
Das heißt, richtig schön gleichmäßig ausrollen,
damit das Brot auch in der Pfanne gleichmäßig backt.
Also nehme ich hier meine Abstandsringe.
Oder ihr könnt auch Teighölzer benutzen.
Ihr könnt zum Beispiel aus dem Baumarkt
Holz holen mit 5 mm Stärke.
Dann habt ihr auch Teighölzer einfach selbst gemacht.
Oder, wie gesagt, einfach die Ringe für den Ausrollstab.
Die werden hier darauf gesetzt
und auf den Ausrollstab darauf gerollt.
Und dann habt ihr hier praktisch
immer diesen 5 mm Abstand
und könnt wirklich alles perfekt gleichmäßig ausrollen.
Also jetzt etwas Mehl nehmen.
Und dann zack, zack.
5 mm.
Und da können die Kinder wirklich schön mithelfen,
ohne dass eben was schiefgeht.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach meinen Gusseisen-Bräter,
weil er schön groß ist.
Ich habe diese rechteckige Pfanne
und habe einfach so viel Platz wie möglich.
Ihr könnt auch eine Teppanyaki-Pfanne nehmen.
Ich habe sie bei mir zu Hause
– also ich bin hier auch zu Hause.
Aber in der anderen Küche, als wir gefrühstückt haben,
habe ich sie, wie gesagt, auf dem Teppanyaki-Grill gemacht.
Supercool!
Ihr könnt aber auch ganz einfach
eine beschichtete Pfanne nehmen.
Also hier ist das wirklich komplett egal.
Ich finde es nur praktisch,
wenn man vier bis fünf gleichzeitig ausbacken kann,
weil man dann eben schneller zum Frühstücken kommt.
Okay.
Jetzt nehmt ihr das hier.
Ich habe es bereits auf mittelhohe Hitze erwärmt.
Da muss ich jetzt echt sagen,
ihr braucht da kein Fett dafür.
Also wirklich einfach trocken ausbacken.
Und ich sage normalerweise immer:
"Nicht Pfannen und Töpfe leer erwärmen,
ohne Inhalt!"
Passt einfach auf, dass ihr ihn nicht überhitzt.
Also jetzt nicht auf PowerBoost,
wie es jetzt der Sturmi machen würde,
sondern einfach auf mittelhoher Hitze langsam erwärmen,
sodass einfach der Bräter sich nicht überhitzt.
Das ist so das einzige Geheimnis dahinter.
Und auch eure beschichtete Pfanne.
Und ich lege jetzt die hier rein.
Ich glaube, die nächsten rolle ich etwas länglicher aus.
Dann passt es auch mit vier.
Und jetzt backt ihr sie einfach
von beiden Seiten für etwa zwei bis drei Minuten aus.
Also ich lasse sie jetzt hier liegen.
Die erste Seite backt.
Dann drehe ich es um.
Und je nachdem, welches Material ihr habt,
kann es sein, dass sie früher oder eben später fertig sind.
Ja.
Das war es.
Und in der Zwischenzeit rolle ich die anderen aus.
[Musik]
Oh, perfekt!
Schaut euch mal die Farbe an!
Jetzt schön noch die zweite Seite ausbacken.
[Musik]
Ich bin jetzt schon fertig.
Also ich habe jetzt
ein bisschen länger als eine Stunde gebraucht.
In der Zwischenzeit habe ich noch
andere Sachen schon gedreht und Rezepte vorbereitet.
Und im Prinzip ist es wirklich ein Rezept,
was supereinfach und ganz schnell geht.
Und ihr könnt sogar, wenn ihr wollt,
den Teig am Abend zuvor vorbereiten,
am besten mit der halben Hefemenge,
den Teig in den Kühlschrank stellen
und am nächsten Morgen dann im Prinzip
nur noch die Bällchen formen, ausrollen und ausbacken.
Oder ihr könnt sogar den Teig aufgehen lassen,
Bällchen formen, abdecken, in den Kühlschrank stellen
und dann am nächsten Tag nur noch ausrollen.
Also da könnt ihr euch wirklich auch
ein bisschen Zeit und Arbeit am Sonntagmorgen sparen,
könnt länger schlafen.
Und ich habe sie jetzt praktisch direkt nach dem Backen
hier auf ein Abkühlgitter gesetzt, damit sie nicht so schwitzen.
Hier mache ich jetzt auch schon mal aus.
Die sind nämlich auch gleich durch.
Und dann, sobald sie ein bisschen abgekühlt sind,
könnt ihr sie auch gerne übereinander stapeln.
Was ich hier jetzt noch mache vor dem Servieren,
einfach noch so ein bisschen das Mehl abklopfen,
was einfach so vom Ausrollen noch über war.
Aber ich würde das Mehl erst nach dem Backen abklopfen.
Denn das Mehl verhindert natürlich auch das Ankleben.
Und jetzt
– kommt, wir suchen uns ein richtig schönes, lockeres.
Josh, willst du dann probieren?
>> JOSH: Ja, gerne.
>> SALLY: Okay. Guckt mal.
Schön locker und luftig!
Und bei Ela mache ich es sogar gerne so,
dass ich es einfach mit einem Messer aufschneide
und ihr ihre Salami oder ihre Tomaten
hier einfach reinfülle.
Und dann hat sie praktisch wie so ein Sandwich direkt.
Und am nächsten Tag könnt ihr es auch wunderbar
noch mal im Ofen aufbacken oder im Toaster aufbacken,
also, wenn ihr was übrig habt.
Ansonsten serviert es einfach gleich.
Mal probieren.
Und nicht zu viel Salz, nicht?
>> JOSH: Überhaupt nicht.
>> SALLY: So ein Esslöffel sah schon viel aus,
aber auf die Mehlmenge
braucht ihr auf jeden Fall einen Esslöffel.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken eures Pfannenbrotes!
Bazlama, wie gesagt, auf Türkisch.
Ich finde, das erinnert auch so ein bisschen an Naan-Brot,
an dieses indische Pfannenbrot.
Wobei die meist noch etwas dünner gemacht werden,
so ein bisschen knuspriger sind.
Und ich finde es einfach Hammer!
Wenn ihr mal keine Lust habt, zum Bäcker zu gehen,
kein Brot dahabt,
macht einfach Bazlama!
Viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Postet auf jeden Fall eure Fotos!
Verlinkt mich darauf!
Und wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten Mal!
Tschüssi!
Und lasst eure Kinder mitbacken!
Die können das wirklich wunderbar.
Es macht ihnen Spaß.
Und führt sie einfach so ein bisschen an die Küche ran!
Und ja, dann habt ihr euch
auch später ganz fleißige Helferlein in der Küche.
[Musik]